divisez faut pas dire qu'ils sont comme
ça ils sont comme ça ce qu'est ce qui
est terrible dans cette histoire c'est
de se dire qu'il ya des gens depuis mois
de mars ils ont pas travailler alors
bien évidemment c'est le jury pour les
intermittents et moi je vais aller plus
cash moi pour vous je m'inquiète pas
pour ceux qui sont hautes comme utiliser
la partie de l'iceberg
je m'inquiète même pas pour vous aimer
c'est l'iceberg c'est pour tout ce que
vous faites travailler oui oui je suis
fait pour sa gueule en outre nous voilà
je suis là c'est pour ça que tu l'as dit
alors c'était très bien c'est cela qu'il
faut à converger l'iceberg c'est cela
qui de l'iceberg
et c'est cela qu'il faut aider et qu'il
faut pas laisser bien sûr parce que
philippe l'a dit le gouvernement
j'aimerais pas être à sa place
vous prenez l'exemple des gens il ya des
gens on leur dit restez chez vous et on
va vous payer on leur dit pas aux gens
par exemple qui sont qui sont mis en
galère depuis mars
on leur dit pas comme les artistes on va
décaler votre votre licenciement
le licenciement ils vont se manger dans
la tête ou des cas un rap à janvier je
vois des artistes je suis dégoûté
maternelle des calèches 15 janvier 2021
mais c'est décalé le licenciement s'est
tout de suite n'est joué ni collabos dos
je vais lui dire à nicolas bedos
c'est tout cet été quand il faisait des
story sur instagram sur la côte d'azur
camille lelouch c'est pareil les stories
sur instagram à se mettre des murs ils
n'ont pas fait de message pour dire
attention qu'on va se déconfit nez
mettez vos masques parce qu'on va le
payer plus tard ils se sont unis pour
des story maintenant ils se plaignent
maintenant c'était avant qu'il fallait
faire les messages aussi c'est le
gouvernement je pense qu'il fait ce
qu'il veut chez avec le mans j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] je me veut je me j'en ai
je supporte pas ces people qui viennent
comme berné ans à l'époque les gilet
jaune on en a rien à [ __ ]
parce que monsieur va pas pouvoir jouer
son spectacle et les gens voire immortal
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
il ya des gens qui ont perdu leur taf il
ya des gens qui vont perdre leur taf et
agir dès le 12 mai à rien il ya des gens
qui vont être au chômage et les mecs sur
la jadis mais j'adore parce que là il ya
des gens quand même chez eux des
téléspectateurs sont chez eux et à leur
mère qui va arriver mais qu'est ce que
tu applaudis
ça te des sardines et je comprends votre
situation et à des gens au cet été qu'on
dit sortez amusez vous à aller kane fait
plein de trucs mais on s'en fout si
c'est ce moment je connais ce qui a été
dit est aujourd'hui les mêmes gens te
disent pourquoi enfermer librairie mais
enfermé librairie parce que vous avez
été inconscient j'ai pas que c'est c'est
aux stars de donner les messages dit pas
de ça et virgile il se sent un peu
d'accord écrit maintenant c'est à dire
que ça fait de bridge depuis un petit
moment qu'on en dit qu'il faut faire
attention où il y en a pas nouveaux
docks où il couvre pas il faut j'ai des
amis médecins qu'ils n'en peuvent plus
les salles de consultation sont débordés
ils sont même advenir à se dire mais
tant pis vous n'avez pas pris vous
n'avez pas fait attention de bien
regarder si chaud que je suis encore dix
secondes et liez cuzon avaient échoué en
10 secondes on étend couvre-feu 10
secondes des deux champs en étant
couvre-feu il ya des people vous laisse
avait contribué je vais être choisi de
regarder il ya eu le couvre-feu on vous
a dit couvre-feu pour moi c'est une
mascarade il savait qu'ils allaient nous
confiner mais ils nous ont dit que vous
recevrez il ya quand même des artistes
qu'on était dire vous rendez compte on
peut plus aller à 18h30 au théâtre mais
on pouvait y aller quand même le
week-end il y avait quand même une
petite ouverture pour y aller le
week-end au théâtre dont nous avons tant
que chef non je vais je finisse à la
protection derrière un service est plat
le midi les restaurants il était quand
même un petit peu ouvert il ya quand
même des gens qu'on dit non c'est pas
normal on peut pas les voir no mori toi
23 heures
résultat des courses qu'est ce qui se
passe maintenant on ferme notre gueule
on est chez nous on est confiné au
regard de but si on regarde le voisin
c'est tout à fait c'est pas de leur
faute sur la c'est la faute à qui c'est
pas vous je ne dis pas que c'est vous
une fois de plus je différencie bien et
c'est important vos objectifs je crois
que personne aimée faut pas diviser faut
danser divisée j'ai suivi de loin
raymond les le de loi parce que j'ai
aucune compétence ni or ni en politique
n'y renonce line mais je voyais bien que
tout un bep j majine quel gouvernement
dans cette situation la capitale jusqu'à
il ya très peu de temps même les grands
spécialistes de la santé t'es pas
d'accord ok donc ils le sont ils étaient
1 / dire forêts onf ine à partir du
moment où il faut confiner les quelques
un baume à 20 ans il a envie de sortir
et qu'ils s'en foutent rapidement je le
comprends tout à fait donc on va pas le
culpabiliser aujourd'hui nous notre
devoir d'adultes et d'artistes si tant
est qu'on est un peu écouté ce qui
serait d'ailleurs en cours parce qu'on
est pas plus intelligent que les autres
au cou mais en tout cas c'est de se dire
bon alors là c'est le moment de montrer
qu'on est tous solidaires l'a souvent
des vivres lapointe
qu'on pense des téléspectateurs je crois
que nordine a lancé un sondage comprenez
vous les stars qui pousse un coup de
gueule sur leur conférant oui à 44% non
à 50 danois là mais c'est parfait